Let's talk a little bit about some of the specifics for
data modeling in JSON. First thing we should mention, is that
items may have different fields. So you notice there, that for
the certifications that actually had a multiplier, we included that multiplier.
In the case of Hard Days Night, it was four. But
for those that don't actually have a multiplier, we simply left
that field out. And as we just discussed, JSON objects may
have nested objects. That is, fields may have values which are themselves
JSON objects. We can also nest arrays. So, a field may have a value of an
array, and that array may have as it's
elements other JSON objects, individual values, or other arrays.